this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much
um
after all that administration i'm
pleased to tell you i'm doing very
little now
and i'm doing a lot more science and
it's
a lot of fun and one of the things that
i've always found fun is my studies of
isoprene
and so
i'd like to cover
a lot of things so most of them won't be
in great depth but um
i hope it'll tell an interesting story
uh
we wanna i wanted to mention or talk
about global warming and i'll show some
of the requisite slides just so we're
all on the same page about co2 and
temperature
and then
talk about
how these affect photosynthesis
just as a background
on which we'll layer
isoprene and i'll talk about isoprene's
role in the atmosphere
uh and then um
these days we have to call everything
omics so i'll talk about phenomics
genomics transcriptomics and
phosphoproteomics
uh but i hope that it will be an
interesting story
i wanted to do a little bit of history
about global warming
and in particular
uh
savant arenas
but if we look at the history fourier
who is a mathematician and was behind
the furry transform analysis if you've
done any
uh
um
of those
said that
the atmosphere contributes to planetary
temperature
that if you do calculations a planet
this far from the sun should be so cold
as to not support life uh and so why
does it why is it warmer and furious i
said well it's the atmosphere
eunice foot foot
observed that different gases had
heat trapping effects
tyndall that we're going to see later
describes how co2 is blocking
specifically infrared
but arrhenius calculated warming from a
doubling of atmospheric co2 and this
metric
stayed with us for a long time so many
high co2 experiments are
doubling co2
and when i started the co2 concentration
was 330 ppm and so doubling it was going
to 660 ppm
now the co2 concentration is almost 420
so doubling means going to 840. so the
experiments are a little different these
days
yeah sure
so this saucer who
is a photosynthesis guy
measured the co2 concentration in the
alps
but you don't have
[Laughter]
no
this is not my history
yes i just pulled it out history
is incomplete
absolutely
yes yes but i wanted to particularly
point out uh arrhenius now angstrom said
you know arenas analysis is not correct
because there's too much water in the
lower atmosphere and that would make it
blind to co2 and the rhenius came back
and said no the upper atmosphere is dry
uh co2 is going to be a problem so if
you have these kinds of problems these
kinds of disagreements you simply do the
experiment
and that's what we've done
uh co2 concentration for here 800 000
years between 200 and 300 ppm
and then now we're up at 420 ppm
and indeed it causes
uh the temperature to go up um
so
um
these are these are very
clear
things that are
that we're living with today
a couple of other things that aren't
apparent in these graphs is that uh
warming is greater over land than over
oceans so if you talk about a one degree
c global increase you're talking about
two or three degrees c over land areas
so it's really quite a bit more
another thing is that plants experience
the actual temperatures not the average
and so
when you put more energy into the
atmosphere
then you get more extreme events so you
have more times when temperatures are
extremely high
and you don't capture that if you just
simply report averages
and the other thing is
then heat waves are more common and
intense in a high co2 world so i want to
talk about
how these two things temperature and co2
affect photosynthesis and then or
actually first i want to show you
the things we do to analyze temperature
responses
and you can use arbitrary equations uh
as june and evans and farquhar did
to describe in this case
described electron transport as a
function of temperature and they just
use an arbitrary equation and
uh there's nothing wrong with that
actually
people often use this q10 analysis
and the nice thing about that is it's
very intuitive
it simply says if you increase
temperature by 10 degrees
what happens to the rate
of what you're looking at
typically in biological systems it
doubles
but it doesn't describe
the fall off the q10 analysis
if you want to be a little more formal
we use the arrhenius equation so this is
the same arrhenius
that talked about doubling co2
the rate is equal to some
pre-exponential term
times the exponent of this e a is energy
of activation divided by gas constant
and temperature
and what people do with that a lot
is to plot
make an arrhenius plot
you take the natural log of both sides
of this equation and you get very nice
straight lines and you can calculate
then this energy of activation and you
can compare processes
okay does this have a higher or lower
energy of activation
but a more complete equation
is the earing johnson equation
and the nice thing about that is that it
does
account for the decline at high
temperature
it introduces more
variables the delta h a it's enthalpic
energy and energy of activation
and introduces
um
delta s
so those are the ways and and we'll see
uh examples of those uh throughout the
talk
so when we look at photosynthesis
it responds to light um
and then there's a saturation point
where it doesn't respond quite as much
photosynthesis response to temperature
is more modest than most people think
and i'll show you some of the reasons
for that
and then
the response to co2 we know that
responds strongly to co2 and then it
slows down
so
the response to co2 is made up of three
components
one is
just the the properties of rubisco so
you assume that
uh
rubp the substrate is made at faster
rate than rubisco can use it so you've
got rubi rubp saturated
rubisco and that would give you a co2
response that looks like that
can predict very well down here but it
doesn't predict well up here
you can assume that
electron transport limits photosynthesis
you over predict here
but
you catch these points real nicely but
then you over predict here
uh and this is a third
thing we call carbon output um
what happens
as you fix co2 you've got to somehow
deal with the sugar that you've made
yes we cannot see your pointer on the
screen you can't see my pointer thank
you for telling me
let's see if i
can tell right here okay
um
the arrow was there
thanks um
okay so
uh
now
why is it that photosynthesis is less
sensitive to temperature than you would
expect rubisco is an enzyme so many
enzymes have a q10 of about two energy
of activation about 60 000
joules per mole
but what happens is if you assume
the maximum rate of rubisco it has this
very strong temperature dependence just
as you would expect
but
rubisco is operating
at a concentration of substrate co2
that's about the km for co2
and
then the velocity
of the reaction is going to be
proportional to
the v max
and the km divided by km
and both of them
have a strong energy of activation
and so um when you take the ratio
it changes this
behavior
to this behavior here the
middle line
so it makes it much less sensitive to
temperature
uh
you may know this process of
photorespiration where oxygen is fixed
instead of carbon dioxide
uh and that goes uh that increases with
temperature faster than does carbon
fixation and so that changes the that
relationship a little bit more
so uh
rubisco is less temperature sensitive
than you normally would think
in the in the plant
people think that electron transport is
going to be independent of temperature
and the actual process of absorbing
light energy is independent of
temperature
but
when you look at electron transport
you've got to deal with all of the
components of electron transport things
moving through membranes and that kind
of thing
and it ends up with
looking somewhat like that
and then when we look at
carbon output how fast you take carbon
out of the kelvin benson cycle uh you
get a stronger temperature response but
then a decline up here and so we use
that hearing johnson equation
for that
so
with that background
uh i want to talk about
uh plant resilience to global change and
specifically the case of isoprene
it surprises many people it surprised me
when i learned that oak trees give off
more hydrocarbons than pine trees
if you go into pine forest you're well
aware of the mono terpenes being given
off by pine trees
you go into an oak forest and you're not
aware of the fact that there's even more
hydrocarbon and that hydrocarbon is
isoprene we're relatively insensitive to
isoprene
if you're smelling isoprene you're
getting a toxic dose so
do something about that
and the amount that's made by plants not
all plants naked
but
some do and the amount that's made is
just
incredible
so if we look at the total amount of
hydrocarbon including methane in this
case
going into the atmosphere
isoprene is nearly half
of that total
the monoterpenes that you can smell and
have these pleasant smells generally
make up a big component
the the things we worry about
the anthropogenic these are unburned
gasoline and things like that
uh
is only this much
uh so um it's surprising that
hydrocarbon emissions into the
atmosphere are primarily
biogenic primarily natural processes
and they become
they can become a problem
now recognizing this
it was a presidential candidate back in
1980 so for people of a certain age we
all remember this
ronald reagan said
80 percent of our air pollution comes
from hydrocarbons released by vegetation
so let's not go overboard in setting and
enforcing tough emission standards from
man-made sources
and when you follow that
you get this kind of thing
and
i will say i don't think it's all the
trees in los angeles it makes los
angeles look that way
so what is the issue
well
when we look at ozone
so what's happening here is you've got
ozone and you've got hydrocarbons and
you're making particles and they're
scattering light and they're scattering
red light because they're big particles
and so when we look at ozone
we define this
nox you might hear of nox nox
uh as the sum of no and no2
so n2
and o2 is actually
uh
would not exist if you look
if if there was somebody way out in
space looked at the earth and saw
evidence of o2 and n2 existing together
they would say there's something wrong
on that planet because that's not an
equilibrium
now fortunately there's a large energy
of activation
uh and so you don't get that much knocks
but you do get some knocks from
lightning and you get some knocks from
cars a lot from cars in fact
but the total amount of ozone that you
can make
is equal to the total amount of nox that
you have
if you don't have any hydrocarbons
these two reactions happen so at night
all of the nox is as no2
during the day sunlight causes the no2
to break apart you have atomic oxygen
connects to molecular oxygen to make
ozone
now
here's where it gets interesting
if you have isoprene or any other
hydrocarbon
they will interact it will interact with
hydroxyl radicals
um o h not o h minus just oh
and
skipping a bunch of steps that leads to
no2
being made so you're taking some of this
no
and you're converting it back to no2
and you you're leaving some of the
hydrocarbon behind
so
this allows you to make
more ozone
and that hydrocarbon that's left behind
can recycle
and you can make
a lot of ozone
from one isoprene molecule
now if you do these reactions and the
atmosphere is pretty clean you actually
clean the atmosphere with isoprene if
you get a certain amount of nox present
and you add isoprene then you get more
ozone so the
isoprene will contribute to ozone
pollution
so the solution
is to not put knox near
uh so
um
this was recognized some time ago
rye rasmussen
advised the epa
that you should not
put all your eggs in one basket you
should not try to suppress hydrocarbon
we tried to suppress hydrocarbon
emissions from cars
and
it didn't work to lower ozone and the
reason is that cars are only a small
part of the hydrocarbon emission
rye was a student of
fritz wendt and so many people will
remember fritz wendt
for his work with oxen
but he
in later in his life he was just
fascinated with the hydrocarbons coming
from
especially leaves on the forest floor
and he published about the blue
mountains
and
it is the case that isoprene contributes
to aerosol formation
you can do this monoterpenes are even
better so i've got a demonstration
with mono terpenes
you fill this container here
with ozone
and then
you take
a lemon peel and you squeeze it on top
and you can
watch the individual droplets go down
because as they as the hydrocarbon
evaporates from the droplet it forms
particles just that fast
and this is something that tyndall that
we talked about before
had talked about
so hydrocarbons in ozone will make
aerosols and
these can be a problem especially the
small aerosols that are made this way
because they can get right through your
lung tissue into your bloodstream
so
maybe we should just cut down all the
trees
i don't think so
uh
but plants aren't the only organisms
that make isoprene almost everything
does
i was told that i emit ice cream we are
going to test to see if that's true and
how much
it looks like approximately 40 parts per
billion
so everybody that i've ever tested
has isoprene in the breath and for many
people it's the most abundant
hydrocarbon in your breath
uh
second is acetone and we know where
acetone comes from ketone bodies
but
we don't have any clue yet where the
isoprene in our breath is coming from
so
uh the next thing i want to talk about
is
the genomics
if we get the
gene sequences for a bunch of isoprene
synthases
we can start to figure out
the evolutionary history
and
we have
isoprene synthases
here right next the true isoprene
synthesis next to these that at this
time we were calling predicted isoprene
synthesis
um
and
um
i don't say it on here these are mostly
rosids
uh
these are astrid's and the spices
clearly went crazy when it came to uh
monoterpene synthases and that's why
they're
we think of them as spices
but they're right next to
um acyclic
monoterpene synthases
and what we discovered over time is that
there were a few amino acids if you
change a few amino acids you convert one
particular kind of monoterpene synthase
and this is an osamine synthase so this
is osamine
and you see it's similar to isoprene
it's just a little bit longer
and all of the oceanine synthases have
an alanine at a particular location
whereas all the isoprene synthases have
a phenylalanine
at that same location
so that the the pocket is smaller
in the isoprene synthases and it will
only fit the dmadp
what i don't understand is why dmadp
doesn't come in here and why all osmine
synthesis are not isoprene synthesis but
that seems to be the case
but what it means is that it's very easy
for isoprene emission
to evolve
and so we know that it's evolved
independently many many times now quite
a few times just in the angiosperms but
we find it in
lots of different
species and we have no idea what an
isoprene synthase in say mosses or ferns
looks like
we know that that the mosses and the
ferns don't have
any uh genes that are remotely like
the gene for uh isoprene synthase
so uh
next year we're gonna do a big push with
uh the water fern called azola
uh it's a pretty big isoprene emitter uh
and it has been fully sequenced so
we're gonna go in and see if we can find
that gene
all right so now if we look at phenomics
so this is what we
had developed for photosynthesis
and let's look at what happens with
isoprene
isoprene is light dependent
you turn off the light and isoprene
emission stops
it will continue to increase with the
light even after photosynthesis is fully
saturated and we don't know why that is
yet
if we look at temperature
isoprene emission is much more sensitive
to temperature
q10 sometimes of five
which is
just
much greater than any other process
that i know
and a surprising thing and i
warn you now i will not be able to
answer why
is that isoprene emission is suppressed
by high co2
so i will over several slides talk about
this difference of uh
increasing with temperature but
decreasing with co2 which is going to
worn out what will happen in the future
will there be more isoprene or less
so this is the data about
the light response of isoprene emission
francesco loreto
was with me for five years uh
doing great work in italy
now uh collected this data this was
pretty extreme
but
many many people have found this that
isoprene emission continues to increase
with light
after photosynthesis is no longer
sensitive
isoprene emission
requires a lot of atp and requires a lot
of nadph so
this kind of makes sense
when we look at temperature effects
this red line is the temperature of the
chamber so that's how fast we could
change the temperature of the chamber
or of the actually of the leaf itself
and this is
the rate of change of isoprene emission
and we see that there were two
components to this so if you do a
a log plot um
you where you have this break you have
two different components
um and we didn't really understand it at
the time
and one of the ways we address that
is to look at post-illumination isoprene
emission
so if you turn the light off
isoprene emission goes down to zero then
it comes up a little bit and goes back
down to zero
we call this a little burst or a little
burp
and we have to look at how fast isoprene
can clear the chamber and that's this
dashed line
and
uh
what it allows us to do
is to get an estimate of the amount of
immediate precursor to isoprene
uh and the amount of a precursor that's
further up and we've done the gc mass
effect or the lcm aspect
to confirm
that
the integral of this the area of this
is
directly proportional to the amount of
this intermediate and the integral of
this is directly proportional to
the
amount of these two compounds and dmadp
is the compound that is the immediate
precursor to isoprene
now
i want to show you
uh
temperature responses
so
uh as you increase temperature in this
range up to 35
it doesn't matter how fast you go so
uh
if you go really fast the black dots
um then you get this curve if you go so
this is uh spending five minutes at each
uh temperature this is uh spending um
10 minutes at each temperature and this
is spending 40 minutes at each
temperature
so
we wanted to know why that is
you can imagine that if you just do a
jump from 30 to 40 so we jump from here
30 to 40
that over time
there's an increase and then a decrease
so that's what we find here increase and
then decrease
and so we looked at the metabolites
uh here here and here
and what we find is that when you first
increase the 40 degrees
there is a big increase in metabolites
so metabolism goes faster when you go to
high temperature
providing more
of the substrate
and then that substrate goes away after
an hour
at high temperature
if we look at the total amount of mep so
this is
those two different areas we integrate
those two different areas and add them
together there's a nice big increase in
the total amount of metabolites in the
mep pathway and then it goes down
declines
if we look at
the
rate constant for the enzyme
as you go to
as you increase
the temperature the rate constant goes
up as we normally expect for enzymes
and the
rate constant stays the same at 40
degrees
so the reason for this burst is
an initial flood of the pathway with
metabolites followed by
something that restricts the metabolites
and we don't know exactly what that is
so
this is
looking at isoprene emission
as a function of temperature
if we look at photosynthesis it declines
quite a bit at these temperatures
so that the carbon cost the amount of
carbon going into ice cream
at 25 degrees is maybe only one percent
but by the time we get to 45 degrees
we're looking at 20 percent of the
carbon coming in is coming straight back
out as isoprene
and that's a function of two things one
is
increasing metabolites and
increasing activation of isoprene
synthase and if we do an arrhenius plot
we get a nice straight line telling us
that everything is working just fine
with the enzyme
now those are all instantaneous
temperature effects we also looked at
long-term temperature effects and with
poplar
it's a
sometimes when you grow it it will
continuously flush continuously make new
leaves
and so we have
if we look at this developmental scale
we have we can look at one point and
look at
the age different aged leaves and what
we see is that when we study
photosynthesis as the leaves develop
photosynthesis comes up and it's pretty
much the same whether you're developing
at 20 degrees or 30 degrees
later on
30 degrees has a slightly higher
photosynthetic rate
but for isoprene
even after the plants are relatively
competent for photosynthesis
the isoprene comes on much slower
at 30 degrees not that much slower but
at 20 degrees quite a bit slower
so if you grow plants at different
temperatures
plants grown at low temperature
have a lower
rate
for a lower capacity for photosynthesis
so we wanted to study that
going back and forth and amy weiberly
did this experiment
where she had plants that had developed
at 20 degrees c
measured isoprene
she had plants that developed at 30
degrees c
and measured isoprene
always measuring at 30 degrees c
and then she switched
from the low temperature to the high
temperature isoprene emission went up
okay that makes sense
she switched from the high temperature
to the low temperature
and isoprene emission went up
and in fact the pattern that we saw was
that
whenever you make a change
there's an initial increase in isoprene
emissions
that then goes away in the long term if
you grow plants at higher temperature
they have a higher capacity for isoprene
emission
there's not a lot
happening with photosynthesis other than
initially at low temperature it was low
but it's relatively insensitive to
growth temperature photosynthesis is
whereas isoprene is very very sensitive
all right the next thing i want to talk
about is the co2 response so here's the
co2 response of photosynthesis
nice pretty curves this is
a photosynthetic electron transport we
can get at that with chlorophyll
fluorescence analysis
and then when we look at isoprene
emission
it doesn't follow any one of those we
have not been able to correlate isoprene
emission to any parameter
of photosynthesis we've looked at a
whole bunch of different parameters
we cannot correlate it with anything
uh
if we
look at it at different temperatures
here we see again this incredibly strong
uh temperature response of isoprene
emission capacity this is
uh so at
low co2 we go from 10
to almost 40 so q10 close to
four
and
photosynthesis
at these three different temperatures
pretty much all the same electron
transport pretty much all the same so
none of these things
in these two help us explain this
so we have this question uh
in the future
what's going to happen
will high co2 suppress isoprene emission
or will the high temperature cause it to
be stimulated
and
we had an undergraduate student come for
the summer
and she tested in four different uh
conditions we have uh
tobacco plants that were engineered by
claudia vickers to uh make
um
isoprene so we have plus and minus
isoprene there
we have phragmites
we have
sycamore and we had poplar
and in the tobacco
there wasn't a
significant difference we measured at
400 ppm at 28 degrees and 800 ppm at 33
degrees because uh
as far as when we looked at the modeling
and that uh it said that by the time you
get a doubling to 800
that there would be a five degree c
increase in the temperature that these
plants would experience
but for the phragmites the sycamore and
the poplar they all have a higher
emission
in the future atmosphere
so the temperature response is greater
than the co2 response
so we're likely to get that
knowing that there's that much isoprene
being produced we ask the question what
does it do for the plant why do some
plants make isoprene
and so this was one of the early
experiments
we gave the plant three heat spikes
going to 42 degrees celsius
for two minutes this is an oak leaf
uh the plus means that the oak leaf is
still making isoprene the minus means
it's not making isoprene uh because of
an inhibitor fosmitamycin
and after these three heat spikes we've
lost three we've lost one third of the
capacity for making isotreat
but in the absence of isoprene we've
lost two thirds
so it
allows the plant to tolerate these heat
spikes
much better if it's making isoprene
of course we want to do it with
arabidopsis if you give a rabidopsis 20
ppm isoprene
it survives better not great
but it survives better uh 24 hours at 40
degrees c and some of my colleagues
around the world have found the same
things that uh it protects against this
kind of really
significant heat stress
we're also looking at protection against
ozone
and so
bianca serta is
giving an ozone treatment to a section
of the tobacco leaf
and then exposing it to ozone giving
isoprene treatment then exposing it to
ozone
or she
doesn't give it the isoprene
pretreatment
just expose it to ozone and you can see
as the days will go on
there's complete destruction of the
leaves
by this ozone treatment and almost
complete
protection
if they're first exposed to ozone and
um
this is happening even though there's
not isoprene present when there is ozone
being given
so you give a pre-treatment with
isoprene and that changes the plant
somehow so that it can then tolerate the
ozone
we did another experiment chris harvey
did this
where he exposed the plant to methyl
vinyl ketones so isoprene the first
reaction that breaks down isoprene in
most cases in many cases is splitting it
into methyl vinyl ketone and
methacrylate
and methyl vinyl ketone is what's called
a michael's addition
chemical uh and it's reactive
causes oxidative stress
and if we take our control
arabidopsis
and give it isoprene
we don't change the amount of hydrogen
peroxide in the leaf
if we give methyl vinyl ketone we do
change we get hydrogen peroxide buildup
so there's raw stress
if we give methyl vinyl ketone and
isoprene
we get no change from the background
level
so that
isoprene
prevents
the reaction
causing excessive hydrogen peroxide but
it doesn't quench hydrogen peroxide
itself
so it attacks the synthesis of hydrogen
peroxide that's what we believe
for a long time i had pushed the idea
that this was related to
isoprene dissolving into membranes
and chris as a graduate student
dared to contradict me
and he showed that if he takes
uh nitrogen
humidifies it adds isoprene
now you can't bubble through a solution
of
vesicles you get just
bubbles
but you let it equilibrate here a lot
and then you let it equilibrate with
just the buffer solution
and then you take samples from here and
you strip the isoprene out
and what he found is that
when there was either
thylakoid vesicles or just a
model membrane lipid
there was more isoprene
and so this is the isoprene that was in
the membranes
so then we can take that amount of
isoprene in the membranes
and compare it to how much membrane
there is so for every 1 million membrane
molecules there was only about 64
isoprene molecules
so
it really is not
isoprene dissolved into membranes
all right
so we did some
uh rna-seq
and we found just an incredible variety
of
genes that were expressed
we've tried to
organize these one of those clear
signals was ja
synthesis signaling
so the
oxygenases and many other
things that are involved in ja synthesis
and phenylpropanoid synthesis
was affected a great
deal other things there wasn't there was
some
cytokine and not a great deal
if we
uh organized it a little differently
again a small amount of cytokinin signal
strong jasminic acid signaling
funny with aba there's some signaling
increasing and some decreasing and aba
effects are known to be that way that uh
there are some aba effects more
connected with drought and other aba
connect effects connected with other
things
the salicylic acid
was suppressed and there's a very common
balance between jasmonic acid and
salicylic acid when one is stimulated
the other is inhibited and vice versa
so sarothy
put these all together these dashed
lines are all
effects that we saw as a result of
feeding isoprene
and these are all
transcription factors
and so they start a number of processes
that change growth and we think change
the ability of the plant to tolerate the
various stresses that we would throw at
it
we did phosphoproteomics
and
some of those were surprising
for example chloroplast movement
um
well that's
who i wanted to yeah okay
so chop one and folk two if you know
chloroplast movement um chop one
connects the cytoskeleton to the
chloroplast and photo is a blue light
sensor
and
so there are changes this is one hour of
isoprene treatment
followed by five hours
followed by uh extraction and doing the
phosphoprotein
but there were other ones that were
quite surprising to me
a number of sugar metabolism
proteins were changed in phosphorylation
status
rna binding and processing the
pab4 i think is involved in these
stress granules inside the nucleus
and
so
we haven't we don't know what these
things all mean
if you know you're membrane protein
trafficking genes
some of those were phosphorylated
receptors
and then
signal transduction pathways like kinase
kinase kinase 7
is a very common
signal transduction
pathway
a lot of it is involved with
connected to
this enzyme which has both a kinase and
phosphatase domain it's a
pp2c phosphatase and a kinase
both together
so
just more transcription factors
uh
i think
in the interests of time i will just say
that
we've been trying to put these all
together in different pathways
um
and
uh
some of it's making a lot of sense but
um
it says that isoprene is affecting gene
expression and also phosphorylation
status uh post-translation
post-translational modifications
just one other observation
we don't know why but we have
arabidopsis strains that make isoprene
and those that don't
and
here are seeds of arabidopsis strains
that make isoprene and they grow longer
roots than the controls
but if you grow controls and
isoprene emitting lines together
you get the same root lengths regardless
so this is a kind of
isoprene signaling uh from the ones that
are making isoprene to the ones that
aren't so if you grow them in separate
petri plates
um
the
isoprene emitting
plants have
longer roots
if you grow them together in one petri
dish they all have the same length of
roots
okay so
that's the story i wanted to tell you
about the role in the atmosphere the
phonomics genomics metabolomics
um
but the role in plants then we think is
to do with abiotic stress
especially temperature and ozone
uh and i think isoprene doesn't quench
ross a lot of people think that but i
don't think it
quenches it but it prevents it from
being made
and prevents ozone damage in that way
there's a story about biotic stress but
we'll leave that for another day so
i want to thank you for
listening and
here are the people that are working on
that now
and
i think especially nsf who's
funded this off and on for many years
thank you
thank you so much tom
very informed informative i can learn a
lot questions plus
yeah so so isoprenes that you that are
defensive it is coming from the plastic
or from the
downstream the method and not the fda
it's definitely a map pathway why is
that is it does it hinge on a specific
gene or one gene or
there's just one gene um
all organisms have dmadp dimethyl allyl
glyphosate and dimethyl diphosphate
would spontaneously break down to
isoprene it's actually a bit of a
problem uh but nowhere near the rates
as in plants and as these isoprene
synthases and so we've cloned them a lot
and uh you know measure them in the test
tube and
um
and then the other thing is we
feed c1302
and we see that it labels up really
really fast isoprene labels up very fast
and if we inhibit the mep pathway with
cosmetomycin we knock out isoprene
emissions so
it's definitely in the plastid
yes it is the
action spectrum
of isoprene emission the same as the
action spectrum of photosynthesis
yeah we haven't done real detailed
analysis but uh i think so
um but are you thinking maybe the uh a
disequilibrium between ps1 and ps2 or
something no i'm not thinking in a
detail
oh okay i loved your seminar okay
yeah
another question i know you talked about
the ozone aspect of isoprene but do you
know the scattering
spectrum of isopropyl
no we don't know this
don't know the spectrum but we assume
that it's just uh raleigh scattering
which is
just
wavelength dependent
the shorter wavelengths are scattered
more than longer wavelengths and that's
why
no peaks as far as i know
but
you might know
does raleigh scattering
have a oh really doesn't but yes
high supreme
yeah isoprene doesn't absorb in the
visible it does absorb in the
uv
um
but not in the visible
so okay one more question um
are dolly calls used for
sugar transport across membranes in the
plastic
i don't know i mean i only know of
dollar calls in human medicine
um
i i presume that but i would presume
that they're more important in the er
but but we don't know that the effects
of isoprene are in the plastic we know
the synthesis is in the plastic but the
effects could well be in the er
but the dollar calls
are made from the methylonic acid
pathway so i think it's i'm pretty sure
they are
uh
any other questions yes
um that was an awesome talk i learned so
much about isoprene thank you so much um
so my first question is related to the
root growth pattern you saw at the very
end there i was kind of curious about
whether
you know i've heard of maybe does the
isoprene
the lack of isoprene production i guess
here would it possibly affect the
oxidation patterns in the roots there
and maybe have implications for soil
carbon
do you know
i hadn't thought about that but
it could well yeah okay
um and the other part of my question was
so you shall show that with climate
change you're expecting more isoprene
production
i was wondering whether
you know any feedback moves with climate
change isoprene production and maybe
microbial degradation of ice cream or
usage or anything like that is there
anything
looking into
uh no i i'm not looking into it there is
microbial degradation of isoprene
um but it's it's much less than the
in the air it's much less
microbial effects are much less than the
destruction by hydroxyl radicals and and
ozone itself
but in the soil
you know the things could be quite
different i i just recently established
a system for growing plants
aeroponically so hydroponics work well
but the plants don't grow quite the same
and if you grow them aeroponically you
just make a mist
uh that the roots are hanging in they
they look a lot closer to the way they
look in soil
so we're going to start
doing
fumigations of the root zone separate
from the shoots
cool awesome thank you yeah thank you
any other questions
okay let's take questions from zoom
there were like more than 70 spokes to
joining our zoom
so thomas yeah thank you for your
patience for keeping your hand
up
so hi this is thomas bjorkman so thanks
for coming to cornell good to see the
update on this story
so i was wondering there's
not intense work but there's uh interest
in
breeding for increased climate
resilience in crop plants ornamental
landscape plants and possibly even
forestry plants
um
for the various manifestations of high
temperature in
injury
um
and so i wonder whether um
you see opportunity for using
uh isoprene as a
breeding for isoprene as a protection
for those high temperature events
yeah um we we argue that both ways uh
one is
we should make
we should
uh have plants make isoprene it would be
very easy to make soybeans make isoprene
the the precursor to soybeans glycine
soja
makes isoprene and has proper ice cream
synthesis the isoprene synthases in in
glycine max
seem to be non-functional
so we could
make soybeans make isoprene now are we
improving things or making things worse
so they're more tolerant of ozone
but they're making isoprene which
contributes to ozone
um
we we argue back and forth i don't know
um
what the best thing is but i think that
for me this is one of the reasons i like
to do this research
because as we understand more and more
of this we might be able to answer your
question exactly that is this a trait we
should put into crops or is this a trait
we should take out of the plants that
we're using
yeah thanks
thank you any other questions from zoom
audience
okay
actually i have a question related to
what thomas asks
say
you talk about climate change that's
just the main like pattern but
of course more heat waves so i would
assume there would be like isotonic
emission volcano like um during those
heat waves and that would probably be
like much much more than
what would be the main warming would you
use right that's exactly right yes uh so
um if you have a
hot spell of four or five days
each day the uh
capacity for making ice cream would be
going up because it's growing in a
warmer temperature
and
uh
also each day the temperature's warmer
and so they're emitting more
of their capacity a greater and so uh i
think this is why these heat waves
become such a problem for uh
atmospheric
um
for air pollution
because you're
putting in so much hydrocarbon uh from
the isoprene yeah yeah okay yeah i have
another nice question of
how uh
because like mpq chemical function is
another um
plants protected by mechanisms
so are they correlated with each other
not at all
we we tested npq we tested
electrochromic shift we tested
photosystem one we tested
uh nothing explained it uh um
for a long time i was sure it was this
carbon export process uh tpu
and we
decidedly proved that was not the case
10 years of hypotheses down the drain so
okay yeah thank you very much
yeah okay so let's uh
uh
thank tom again for this excellent talk
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu